so now they're asking for eleven
thousand dollars in bail money to get
them out this woman named Nancy
transferred more than twenty five
thousand dollars to her internet
boyfriend and then she found out that it
was a scam the dating scam is a
terrifying method to Swindle people out
of their hard-earned money you might
think that some loner is behind this but
in fact there are whole criminal groups
with translators copywriters
photographers and many others they
create fake profiles luring individuals
through romantic gestures for years and
then trick them into shelling out
hundreds or even thousands of dollars
they seem genuine and kind at the outset
but their only aim is to rob people
blind so how can you spot a romance
scammer they move quickly
they may ask to send money to buy a
ticket they may complain that they broke
an expensive camera and ask you to buy a
new one through a fishing site where all
the money from the bank card will be
stolen or they'll just sell the one you
sent don't let a scammer break your
heart and your bank keep your love life
safe and your wallet fatter foreign